this is our last and final session of
not only today but of the whole
conference and our final speaker on this
stage is Bartosz Milewski party she has
a PhD in theoretical physics from
university of flood foaf after working
as a postdoc at universities in europe
and states he switched to programming
and joined Microsoft there he led the
team that implemented the windows search
engine and he has written a book about
object-oriented programming in C++
his interest in parallel and concurrent
programming led him to the study of
functional programming and then to
category theory
he teaches category theory not on his
youtube channel and has written a book
category theory for programmers based on
his popular block and he's not working
on all these topics in his free time he
likes to do rock climbing he's going to
talk about why algebraic data types are
important please give a big round of
applause for Bartos
[Applause]
well thank you this is really a great
pleasure for me to be here for several
reasons one of the reasons is this is
this is where I actually studied physics
this is the city where I studied the
University here and then the second
reason is that after I left physics and
after working at Microsoft I actually
came back in the 90s and as one of my
students reminded me I was I taught C++
here at the University at the physics
department I actually started teaching
C++ for a semester so in a sense I have
my little contribution here too to this
fact that there are so many C++
programmers now in in broad swath some
of them my students and and back then in
the 90s C++ was was not that yet such a
big thing and an object-oriented
programming in general was was was a
relatively new thing and I always I
always tried to like you know look ahead
what will become the new thing and and
and eventually C++ became the big thing
that
it is well almost up to now right I mean
it's still popular right but but this
this was in the past and and I always
try to look into the future and and so
so I switched from C++ I started
programming in Haskell and and that led
me to category theory and to math so so
this is what I think the future is okay
so I'm sort of going to go against the
the general tenor of this conference
because I'll really I'll be criticizing
C++ in a way okay I think there are
great things about C++ and there are
things that are not so great right and
we should look at other languages as
well and and look at and the theory
behind programming languages and we
should also look at mathematics and and
as you know you know there are people
who are like talking about how important
mathematics is in programming we are all
mathematicians really I mean you might
you might say you might not realize that
you're a mathematician being a
programmer but you are this is we are
doing mathematics in our own way so
looking into what mathematicians do that
is related to programming is important
and it will become more and more
important in the future so that's my
main point but today I want to
concentrate on
types on the type system okay it turns
out that the type system has very strong
mathematical foundations even though you
might not notice this if if you only
know the type system of C++ but there
are problems okay so what is what is the
problem what's the problem with a type
system hmm
so without mentioning any particular
language and most strongly typed
languages have a pretty ad-hoc type
system it's a type system that was built
incremental II and it was built
bottom-up right so so like a lot of C++
programmers or C / C programmers they
they would say what's a type well it's
like it's it's how you store the stuff
in memory right how the bytes are
arranged or bits and bytes right that's
a very low-level way of looking at
things right and and you know as long as
you are looking at things like integers
by its characters and so on well that
sort of makes sense right or doubles you
know they are stored in memory and there
is a certain particular order of bytes
and bits and and so on so yeah but then
you are looking at data structures
are more complex you know there are
vectors there are trees they're linked
lists and there are data structures that
won't even fit in memory okay there are
there are data structures like well even
in C++ nowadays you can you can start
thinking about infinite data structures
okay maybe not yet but I know that Eric
nibbler is working on on the range
library and his next big project in in
range library is the lazy ranges and the
lazy range is something that can
describe an infinite data structure how
does it an infinite data structure work
it's not what's stored in memory anymore
okay an infinite data structure will not
fit in memory right so it has to be
implemented lazily meaning when you are
accessing a particular thing using a
particular offset in this data structure
and so on there is a function that's
executed right and it either calculates
this data or or reads it from disk or
from the internet and so on right so so
so this this connection between what's
stored in memory and what a type is
becomes less and less important
and then there is the problem of
generics and and I'm using the word
generics maybe not in the exactly the
same way as Shawn was talking about and
and he will probably be mad at me and
say that this is not what alex
Stepanov calls generic types but I'm
thinking of generic types as generic
algorithms generic types as things that
that will work for for multiple types
right for things that don't look at the
particular type there are not specific
to a particular type like if you have
and you know whether you have a vector
of integers or doubles and you want to
sort it it doesn't really matter whether
it's integers or doubles as long as you
give me a way to compare them right and
and since I mean if you listen to two
Shawn's presentation he went through the
history of generics and and how these
things were added to C++ and they were
added as an afterthought okay I mean was
a great design and everything right but
it wasn't like it wasn't in the language
from the very beginning so C++ has these
layers of things you know it's like it's
it's it's like biological evolution
right you you have some organs that used
to do something else and now they are
used for something else right
so so this is our c+ bars evolved I mean
like the templates were supposed to just
you know if you want to have a list of
integers of a list of boolean right you
write a template it's sort of like a
better macro but then they evolved into
these beasts that are just now like
totally functional language of template
metaprogramming and so on now there is a
good theory for types okay there is a
mathematical theory there are actually
several mathematical theories right I
mean so so Alex de Bono has his own
theory which is more concerned about
performance and how things are evaluated
and so on then there is a mathematical
theory of types there's a type theory
and there's there's part of logic and
[Music]
but this is a very complex theory it's
it's like a very very abstract even for
mathematicians this is this like a very
high level of abstraction so so no
wonder this this theory is pretty much
ignored by most language designers
but the problem is that without these
good basics so like if you start
building the type system from the bottom
up and you just keep adding layers and
layers as the need arises you know you
you have to deal with with with things
that happened in the design and they
just don't fit as well like if you if
you design a system as one big thing
based on some very solid theory it
should be much easier than if you just
incrementally rediscover things is
essentially the type system was
rediscovered by programmers and and all
these elements and I will talk about
this how the theory interacts with with
practice right and and you'll see that
these things that you know from
programming that actually they have
mathematical basis and but but it was
discovered kind of later that they
correspond to certain things and for
instance that the algebraic data types
right the algebraic data types are
really part of of type theory of this
very very abstract theory but we got
there
from some totally different direction
and and now that we are comparing this
with what mathematicians are saying we
see we see that okay so maybe there is
not such a great fit and we made a few
mistakes there and we should have done
it a little bit differently so let me
let me just like days.you a little bit
with with what what a systemic type
theory is and and you understand why
people don't really want to learn it
because it's so so it's based on
something called Martine love type
theory so there was this mathematician
and and he came out with with this with
this theory and and it was part of
mathematics it was it was really type
theory was invented to to fix the
paradoxes of set theory you know there's
this Russell's paradox and other
paradoxes like type like set theory is
paradoxical and unless you start doing
some additional stuff and and one way of
doing this is introduce types okay so
Martin love type theory introduced types
that follow certain algebra of types and
this is why it's called algebraic data
types and now I'll introduce them one by
one so you'll see how they how they work
this is actually even more general
because it turns out that like the
complete type theory contains also these
dependent types and you might know a
little bit of dependent types from C++
amazingly C++ in the templates actually
you can you can parameterize a template
by using a value like like an integer
right not only template of class T but
it could be template int n right so this
this kind of dependence of type on an
integer on a value
it's called dependent time but but what
what c++ is doing is sort of like just
scratching the surface of dependent
types then there is category theory okay
and category theory it turns out that
whatever you do in in type theory can be
translated or modelled in category
theory and and it also can be modeled in
in in logic so category theory is like
Haskell programmers know these these
words right I mean and and more and more
people actually start using these words
more and more programmers are talking
about things like functors no not the
misnomer the C++ misnomer functor is a
function object right well the functor
is something that operates it's a family
of types with certain properties there
are things called mono eats and I I
heard
mono it's mentioned today so I know that
this is something people talk about even
in C++ conferences and of course monads
right I don't know what was where Mona's
mentioned during this conference I know
in corridors but yeah okay cool I mean
there was a talk about futures right in
futures are definitely monads
okay and there is a third sort of leg of
this type varies is intuitionistic logic
right and intuitionistic logic is as
part of logic that it's also called
constructivist logic where you actually
look at theorems and propositions and
proofs so it's like operations on proofs
how do you make a proof of something
from proofs of other things right and
there is a and and and all these three
things actually are isomorphic it's
really the same theory but it's using
different language so type theory some
subset of category theory and
intuitionistic logic they are all the
same but that's really a weird thing to
say but they are the same they have
exactly like one-to-one correspondence
between statements if you prove one
thing in type theory you can apply it to
logic if you prove it in logic you can
apply it to category theory and so on
and the great advantage of having a
well-defined type system that's defined
using these algebraic data types and so
on is that there is this wonderful thing
called hindley-milner type inference
which which lets the compiler figure out
types of things it's like you know
strongly typed languages like C++ they
have these very complex types sometimes
like the type of an iterator you know
it's like people were writing these
types of iterators for a long time and
they're really god upset about that and
and eventually the auto keyword was
introduced in C++ right so Auto keyword
means that let the compiler figure out
the type if there is enough information
in my code right
but auto only works in certain special
circumstances it's it's not totally
general right but if you have a type
theory if you have two type system in
your language that's based on type
theory then actually there is an
algorithm that lets the compiler figure
out the types and why is it important
because a lot of people complain you
know I don't like writing these complex
types this is like a lot of typing right
no pun intended
and you don't have to really I mean in
Haskell we have this hindley-milner type
type system and and and the compiler can
figure out almost all types I mean there
are some types that cannot figure out
but in 90% of the cases it can figure
out types doesn't mean that the Haskell
programmers don't write types because
types are useful
in their own way so they use types but
if it's obvious you don't have to do it
the compiler will figure it out so for
me generic programming is really about
abstracting over types so you want to
write some code that is independent of
the type of things that it's operating
upon right
so in order to abstract over types just
like we abstract over values you know
it's like what do we do well we we write
functions that accept values and produce
other values we can do the same with
types we can write functions on types
these are called type constructors type
constructors are functional types and
and in C++ we have templates templates
take types and produce types right so it
is a function on tight now in order to
define a function on types okay so how
do you define functions in general if a
function is defined you know here's the
function and on the right hand side of
the function definition is the
implementation of the function and the
implements implemented in the simplest
case it's just an expression right so
what's an expression on ties well if you
want to write an expression on types you
have to have some kind of algebra on
type so that you can say okay take this
time in this type and I add them or
multiply them or take a power or so on
okay
it turns out that you can do this you
can do operations on types and you can
form expressions on types and you can
use these expressions to produce
functions on types which is the way of
abstracting stuff over types
and once you have this well then you can
say okay so if I have functional types
can I now implement functions that take
functions on types as arguments or
return functions own so you treat
functions on types of first-order
objects right that you can operate upon
and and this leads for instance this is
something that well in in Haskell for
instance people added this later when
they realize that monads are useful that
you can have a type that is accept a
functional types as an argument or a
type constructor okay so it's like a
higher-order thing now so there are
these higher-order generics like
functors monads and so on now in C++ you
don't really see I guess mmm
none of this although it's theoretically
possible because a function on types is
a template a function on that accepts a
function on types would be a template
that accepts a template template
parameter so if you ever wondered why
are there and the template template
parameters they are to do this kind of
higher-order programming on types
and now once you have these generic
types well you want to perform
operations on these at runtime right so
you need functions that accepts these
generic things and these functions that
accept generic things they have to work
independently of what type you gave it
right therefore they have to be
polymorphic so polymorphic comes up
naturally when you have generic
programming you know you have you have
to have a function that takes a list of
T where T is any type right a function
that takes a list of T and sorts it or
it's best that's it that's a generic
function it's a polymorphic function
because it accepts multiple types okay
and there are two types of polymorphism
and I guess C++ is mostly into ad hoc
polymorphism but but there is this thing
called parametric polymorphism when when
you do you can define a function that
accepts any type like any type that you
can think of it will work for it
there aren't that many functions like
this because usually you want to do
something like you want to compare
things or something and not every type
can be compared not every type can be
turned to string except in Java so so a
generic type has no properties and no
operations no methods on it right
so usually you narrow down this this
kind of parametric polymorphism to some
classes of objects
so let me talk about algebraic data
types okay because this is like the
basic basic of of type theory and like
anybody who who does functional
programming in Haskell sort of
understands what algebraic data types
are but but it's worth it's it's really
worth spreading this information and so
that everybody knows what algebraic data
types are and recognizes them okay they
exist in C++ so the first thing is
product so we'll be talking about
products sums and Exponential's okay so
this is this is the algebra product
means you multiply things sums you add
things and Exponential's you take powers
right
so what are products of types products
of types are implemented in in every
language really I mean every language
implements products and they are just
given different names so like the
simplest product is a pair because it
takes you know two different types and
makes a pair from these types so in C++
this is really a very complicated class
in the standard library called pair
right that takes two types t1 and t2
right then create a structure out of
them that pairing of types is called the
product why is it called the product
well because I mean think think of it
when you have types that they only have
finite number of elements like boolean
has only two true and false right color
let's say has three RG and B right if
you multiply them together you'll get
six possibilities right it could be true
with red true with green true with blue
false and so on right so you get six
possibilities so a pair that contains
the boolean and the color has six
possible values which is two times three
okay and this is like a Cartesian
product of these two sets and this can
be generalized to infinite sets as well
so you can have a pair of int and double
and so on
you can also have so this is a product
of two types you can have product of
three four five types and so on and
usually when you have many types you
call this this these things tuples write
to both of three types four types and so
on and and if you have many of these you
probably want to give them names rather
than sale the first element the second
element the third element of my tuple so
when you give them names you call them
structs or records or you call them
classes okay so all these things are
product types and instead theory so so
every every type can be interpreted in
set theory this is not really very
precise but you can think of a type as a
set of values okay so if you think of a
type as a set of values then then then
product type will correspond to the
Cartesian product or a set of pairs
now in tight theory types are defined
these days so there are some fundamental
types and then they can produce new
types by combining them and these these
ways of producing new types are you when
you define a type in type theory you do
two things you you say how this type is
introduced the introduction and how its
eliminated what does it mean
introduction means if you want to
construct a pair of let's say int and
bool what do you have to give me okay
you have to give me a value of type bull
and you have to give me a value of type
int both and then I can create a pair
okay so introduction means really
construction so what does the
constructor of a pair take well it takes
an element X of T 1 and element Y of
type T 2 and of course in class this
gets really really complicated because
you can pass these things by value by
reference by move by pointer there are
so many ways right but from the point of
view of type theory you just give it two
things and it produces a pair
and so in order to create a pair you
need to values
that's what type theory tells you C++
tells you well you can create the type
and then initialize it later right and
usually this is not a very good idea
that leads to a lot of bugs
okay so strictly speaking when you are
creating a pair you should provide these
two values and initialize it immediately
partial initialization is not a good
idea
elimination means the other side so if
somebody gives me a pair okay they say
here's a function accepts a pair what
can I do with this pair well I can
extract the first value or I can extract
the second value this is all I can do
with it right so this extraction and
this is like any C++ it's it's called
get and it's actually parameterize by an
integer so get zero takes the first
value and get one takes the second value
it might be of different types
right so this is and so every type that
you you talk about in type theory has
the introduction rules and elimination
rules okay and then there are some laws
let's say well if you introduce
something with some value and then you
eliminate this value you should get the
same value back right so there is some
consistency that the stuff that you put
in is the same stuff that you take out
which essentially means no mutation okay
so type theory is really like a very
functional thing to do if you'd want to
do mutation I can C++ then then you get
into a more complex system where you
actually have to use monads
so almost all C++ programming is monadic
so you are using monads everyday okay
without knowing this
[Music]
okay so this is this is the definition
of get pretty complicated so why am i
showing you this
because this sort of like upside down
these are like the simplest ways of
combining types that are known in
mathematics and and in haskell for
instance these formulas are extremely
simple basic okay now in C++ all this
seems like it's been added later as an
afterthought and and it's really true
because without templates you cannot
really have product types so so this is
this is instead of building top down you
know C++ is Bill bottom up and then when
you get to this level while you say okay
all these other languages they have
product types and what do we do well
what we'll we'll use templates and would
use this kind of complicated expressions
to implement simple things like product
types okay now
so so you see this this is from from the
perspective of type theory how you
introduce and eliminate types there is
this other perspective from the point of
view of logic what does a pair
correspond in logic turns out that a
pair corresponds to conjunction to end a
and B how does it work well in this view
of of programming as logic you say if
you provide me a value of type T this is
like a proof that T exists
okay so this is called propositions as
types so if you can provide the value of
T it means T is non empty from the point
of view of logic it means you have a
proof of T okay so in order to produce a
pair you need two elements one of type
t1 and one of type t2 two values so you
you have a proof that t1 is non empty
you have a proof that t2 is non empty
then you can prove that t1 and t2 is non
empty right this is how you prove the
conjunction or logical conjunction when
is a and B true when a is true and B is
true right so this is sort of like when
you think about this as in logic it's
like okay but I have end here and I have
end here I'm proving and using and in my
language and so on but from the point of
view of types
okay give me a value of t1 and give me a
value of t2 then I can create a pair and
that corresponds to t1 and t2 okay so
these are products and as I said
products are everywhere in all languages
right
no not so not so great okay so what's
the sum of two types so a sum of two
types in in Haskell it's called
either if you take two types and you sum
them in general these are these are
target unions and in a way class
hierarchies also correspond to some
types because as some okay so let me let
me show you how some types are are
introduced
okay so tagged unions in in C++ are
implemented as variants and this is also
like a pretty recent addition to two to
standard library right I mean other
other programming languages had variants
I think Java had variants first and then
C++ I'm not sure but so so so variants
are some types
and this is this is the definition of a
variant in in the standard library so it
takes a a bunch of types right so this
is like a list of types t1 t2 t3 blah
blah blah right and it produces a
variant in set theory this is called a
disjoint union so so it's a union of two
sets so it says you know you have a set
of integers and you have a set of
boolean x' a union of these two is just
as you have an element of a union is
either an integer or a boolean right
there's this either/or so how many
different elements can you have well you
of the union you have the number of
elements in the first plus the number of
elements in the second because you
either have an element from here or an
element from here so you just sum them
up right so if you have boolean and
color you will have five possibilities
it's either true or false
being a boolean or it's red green or
blue if it's a color five possibilities
some okay so this is some some type and
this is clearly seen in the introduction
law right so so how do you introduce
introduce some well I guess you don't
see that very clearly from
in C++ but the idea is you can construct
a some type by providing a value of any
of these types okay so like if you have
a tie if you have a sum of integer and
boolean then you either provide an
integer or you provide a boolean so you
see the difference between product types
when you had to provide both of them
here you provide one or the other and
it's a tagged in Union so it's tagged by
what you put in so did you put integer
or did you put a boolean now there is a
problem with this that sort of was
missed in the type system so so from the
point of view of type theory this is
called the disjoint Union which means
that if these two sets overlap so we
were not talking about overlapping like
the boolean and and color are completely
different from different sets right but
what if these two sets overlap and in
particular these two sets could be the
same set
so in type theory it's okay to have a
union of integer with integer it will
just have a left integer and the right
integer so it's it's an integer with an
additional tag a my left or am i right
okay
this is something you can't do in C++
because they are tagged by types so
instead of position
it's like left right in in Haskell it's
its left constructor and right
constructor here they are just tagged by
the type this is why there is only this
one constructor because it's tagged by
the type so if you if you call it with a
boolean you'll get the the boolean right
now the the elimination also this is
kinda an afterthought in in in C++
normally the elimination is done by
pattern matching by saying is it left or
right okay was it constructed using the
left constructor on the right
constructor if it was constructed using
left constructor okay then it's of type
t1 if it was constructed using the right
constructor was it is of type t2
therefore if you want to write a
function that takes a some type you have
to write a case statement that says is
it left or is it right and for each case
provide a function that will accept the
particular type so if it's a if it's a
sum of boolean and color then if it's
left and then apply a function to a
boolean and if it's right then you have
a different function that takes an
integer
what are color or whatever right so so
this is this can be implemented as this
visitor pattern in C++ it's it's it's
done by visitor so a visitor
just knows how to deal with these
different types and we'll figure out
okay the union that you gave me has a
boolean therefore I'm going to apply the
function of a boolean or this visitor of
boolean type or if it's if it's a color
then I'm applying a different function
okay but but you see this is like not
really that familiar to C++ programmers
but but product types and some types are
the very very basic constructing blocks
of types okay so I don't know why sums
are treated as badly as they are in C++
and again this can be interpreted in
logic in logic this is an alternative
why is it an alternative because if you
want to construct a some type you can
either provide the value of a or the
value of B and the same is if you want
to prove an alternative a or B you
either have to provide the proof of a or
a proof of B and it's enough you don't
have to prove both of them right
that's what R is
so sometimes correspond to or I want to
stress this this this fact that these
things kind of mesh together like the
type theory and logic are really the
same so that you see that there is a
very very strong mathematical foundation
behind types the next type constructor
is Exponential's
so powers okay so exponential
corresponds to function types and and
again function types is sort of entered
C++ slowly I mean in see function types
didn't even have originally didn't have
a good type it's like the types of
arguments for instance didn't have to be
specified and then they added more
elaborate
type system for functions and so on then
then of course there is there is the the
fact that the lambdas which are a way of
constructing values of type func of
functional function types were added
very late in the game okay so having
first-class functions means that you
have exponential types in in your
language so in set theory function types
or Exponential's correspond to if you
have two types two sets a and B it
corresponds to the set of functions from
million and to be okay the set of all
possible functions from A to B now so so
the symbol for this is in Haskell it's a
aerobee functions from A to B in C++ and
would sort of be B of a in mathematics
is the exponential B to the power of a
where a is the argument B is the type
return type okay why is it an
exponential because if you think about
it how many different possibilities you
have like if you if for finite sets like
you know let's say color to the power of
boolean that's functions that take a
boolean and return a color how many
possible it's it's B to the power of a
so forever so it takes a boolean so for
every boolean value true or false you
will have three possibilities so 3 times
3 times 3 right they say it right is
that everybody checking my mouth okay so
introduction how do we introduce this
type function type
well the introduction is through lambda
okay so this is like the basic way of
introducing a function you just have
some expression and you create a lambda
so this is something that that's been
added to C++ I don't know in 2011 or and
of course there were functions before
lambdas right but there was no way of
introducing a function at runtime it had
to be introduced at compile time now we
can introduce a function at the runtime
lambda and elimination of functions very
simple animation of a function is just
give me an a value and I'll apply the
function to this value okay so this is
how I eliminate a function what can I do
with a function the only thing I can do
with a function is call it execute it
right that's what I do with functions
and this is really the the important
thing logically this this type
corresponds to implication B follows
from a okay see why because in order to
prove be a has to be true right if B
follows on a so if you give me a proof
of a denied then then you get a proof of
B okay
so
every time you implement a function you
are proving a theorem okay think about
this
because I mean an implementation of
function says well if you provide me an
argument a value of the argument type
then I can prove the result I just
calculate the stub and return the result
right I have an algorithm here to
calculate the result from the argument
that you gave me I mean we're talking
really functional programming here like
of course in C++ you could get stuff
from global variables or something like
that or from read from this but in
functional programming
[Music]
you only have at your disposal whatever
you are getting as your input okay
then there is this weird type unit okay
and this is really really confusing
because the unit from the point of view
of set theory unit corresponds to a
singleton set said that has only one
value okay so but in C++
it's called void okay this is like a
major major problem because you know
it's really hard to explain to people
that void actually has a value right
this is because if void didn't have a
value then how would you be able to call
the function that accepts void right you
have to provide value so I mean
conceptually you have to provide this
value to a function that takes void in
order to get the result it just
otherwise it would make sense we
wouldn't be consistent with everything
else I told you right
so there has to be something like this
but you know so a function that returns
a void right what does it mean well it
produces if if void were had no values
then then you would be producing a value
of an empty set empty set has no values
in it right so it's it's really
impossible so in set theory this is a
singleton set the introduction of of
unit so now I had to switch to Haskell
notation because C++ doesn't have the
concept of unit so the introduction is
you can get a value of of Union from
nothing it just is available in the
atmosphere sort of you know it just is
like if you tell me well give me a value
of bullion well then do you want true or
do you want false I don't know which one
do you want but if you give if you say
give me a value of unit well then there
is only one choice here it is okay there
is no elimination because Union contains
no information it just is
okay therefore from the point of view of
logic this is just the truth value the
truth okay you can prove truth from
nothing you know that truth is true by
definition right that's all new one
there's only one possibility
okay
so
this is an exercises what is false right
okay now once you have unit you can
actually start constructing more complex
data types for instance boolean that I
talked about so many times you know
boolean is just a sum of two units can
you see that like because sam says it's
either left or right and what's the
value of left it's unit well so it has
no information the only information in
the sum of unit plus unit is whether
it's left or right and then you can call
left true and right false or all the way
around if you want right so this is
really a sum of two units and unit has
only one possible value torso a sum of
two ones is to write so boolean is just
a two so you see the the the nice
algebra there now there are more of
these algebraic identities okay so for
instance and and I'll be switching now
to more of the Haskell notation but I
think it will be kind of obvious what
will I mean so there this is this
identity one times a equals a okay what
does it mean one is unit times means
product type so a pair a pair of unit
and a is the same as a doesn't contain
any more information than a itself okay
now in C++ we will probably want to
write something like this pair of void
and a is a but this is bad C++ it was
just was not accepted because C++
treats void is a very very special bad
thing right it's like every time you
write a template do you have to say
about what if the type is void there's a
special case and so on but void is not
really a special case it's just this one
type called unit okay and it has only
one possible value so if you have if you
pair a unit with some a there's no more
information than a itself and you can
show it by showing that given an a you
can always produce a pair void a right
given a pair void a you can always
extract a out of it so a and pair void a
are totally equivalent okay here's a
more interesting example right now we
are using Exponential's so if you if you
follow an exponential is a function the
exponent is the argument type so a to
the power of B plus C it means these are
functions from a some type B plus C to a
they take a some type and return an A
and they should be equivalent to a pair
of functions one takes B and returns a
then the other takes C and returns a
okay so here's here it is in in in
Haskell notation because this is much
simpler what what it means that if you
have a function that accepts a sum type
then you have to do case analysis and
figure out is it left or is it right
okay if it's left then I have to apply a
function that takes
be if it's right then I have to apply a
function that takes C so I need two
functions to implement a function from a
some type to a right I need one function
that takes a B and one function that
takes a C right
okay and then here's a simpler case
right so a square is equal a a times a
right very simple algebraic identity
square well 2 means 1 plus 1 right 1
plus 1 is boolean so it's a function
from boolean to a and it's equivalent
trip pair of a's right a times a that
means pair of a's ok well yeah because a
function from a boolean to a contains
only two values the one for false and
the one for true right so you can
memorize it that's just two values you
don't have to calculate anything
so that's that's the notation function
from bull to a is the same as pair of
A's and this one is very interesting I
don't know if everybody can see from the
back a to the product of B times C is
the same as a to the C to the B right
which means that if I have a function
that takes a pair BC or in other ways in
other words it's a function that takes
two arguments a B and C and returns an A
ok a function of two arguments is
equivalent to a function from B that
returns the function from C to a ok this
in functional program is called currying
and this is some i think i think in in
in c++ we call it bind right like you
provide one argument and you get a
function of the second argument right
that's called currying in functional
programming it's a very important
property of the exponential
okay of course I have a lot more stuff I
could talk about but my time is running
out
okay so maybe I'll conclude this this
okay boys I'll show you you know it's
like I have a bunch of other stuff here
boom oh I can't really go fast from in
this infinity and
[Music]
so I just want to show you that you can
go with this algebraic stuff over and
over you know and it's like and and you
you get to things like existential types
for instance that nobody even uses in
even in functional programming people
don't know much about existential types
you know
but this is very very important part of
type system there is recursion okay then
then you can do things like solving
equations okay it's like like a list is
defined using the same equation in which
you have an infinite sum of product okay
this is a cool one so so let me show you
this so you have an equation list of a
la is like a function of a okay it's
it's a list of a list of A's is one plus
a times list of a so interpreting this
from the point of view of type theory
this is this says that list of a is
defined as it's either an empty list an
empty this is the unit right it has only
one value one possible value empty list
okay
am i an empty list or non empty list so
it's a some empty non-empty so it's a
unit plus and what's a non-empty list a
non-empty list is a product it's a pair
right which has the head of the list
which is of type a and the tail of the
list which is of the type la so it's a
recursive definition right
so it's either empty or it's a head with
a tail okay
that's the definition of a list and then
you take this equation and just solve it
okay so all these steps here are really
bad because you cannot subtract types
and you cannot divide by types okay you
can do this algebra but the final result
is that okay this is 1 over 1 minus a
and that's just like oh that's the sum
of an infinite series right a to the
power of n right geometric series that's
I don't know if everybody remembers the
formula from school right so so if you
if you write it down now again so L a is
equal so the some infants um it starts
with N equals zero so it's 0th power of
a which is the unit so it's unit plus a
plus a squared plus a cube plus so on so
on so on right and it it means like a
list of a's is either empty or it
contains one value or it's a list of two
elements of today or else of three
elements of type a or four elements five
elements and so on okay so this is this
is like a non recursive expansion but
it's an infinite expansion because the
list is either empty or one element or
two elements or three elements or so so
the infinite sum of tuples bigger and
bigger tuples
okay
so those that was the fun example so so
this is my definition of generic
programming and then probably will be
beaten over the head about this but for
me generic programming is programming
with types right and and you have to
have things like functions on types
which in C++ are our templates really
right but you build these function on
types using arithmetic expressions and
so you have algebraic expressions so
this is this is where these algebra
makes sense you know it's like you have
to define functions using some kind of
expressions then these expressions are
formed using algebraic data types and
and then you have recursive data lights
which are solutions of these algebraic
expressions okay that's it
[Applause]
you